My name is Diakalola Amujam. I am a recent psychology graduate from Ireland. I am also an aspiring clinical psychologist. Dr. Marion's book, The Clinical Psychologist Collective, has been so helpful to me on this journey to become a clinical psychologist. As I plan to continue postgraduate studies in the UK, I found it extremely useful that this book provided in-depth information on the UK. the declineside application process. I enjoyed reading about the experiences of both qualified and training clinical psychologists. The various narratives were my favorite part of the book, as everyone's story was different and it provided amazing insights into the clinical psychology
我叫迪亚卡洛拉·阿穆贾姆。我是爱尔兰的一名刚毕业的心理学专业学生。我也是一名立志成为临床心理学家的人。马里昂博士的书《临床心理学家集锦》对我成为临床心理学家这一旅程帮助极大。由于我计划在英国继续攻读研究生，我发现这本书提供了有关英国的深入信息，这极其有用。……申请流程。我很喜欢阅读合格的临床心理学家和实习临床心理学家的经历。各种各样的叙事是我最喜欢的部分，因为每个人的故事都不同，它为临床心理学提供了惊人的见解。
journey. I would definitely recommend this book to anyone interested in psychology and aspires to become a clinical psychologist. If a psychopath walked into the room, you think you'd know? Most of us do, but psychology suggests something much more uncomfortable. And that's that the people we're most likely to trust sometimes might be the people we should question the most. Today I'm joined by Dr Emma Kavanaugh, psychologist and author of the psychopath effect as we explore why charm can be so persuasive, why love bombing works, and while the real psychology isn't necessarily about the psychopaths, it's about the effect they have. have on the rest of us. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent and this is Psychology Actually. Hi, welcome
旅程。我绝对会向任何对心理学感兴趣并立志成为临床心理学家的人推荐这本书。如果一个精神病态者走进房间，你觉得你能认出来吗？我们大多数人都会这么认为，但心理学表明了一些更让人不安的事情。那就是，我们最信任的人有时可能是我们最应该质疑的人。今天，我请到了心理学家、《精神病态效应》一书的作者艾玛·卡纳瓦尔博士，我们将探讨为什么魅力如此具有说服力，为什么“轰炸式示爱”会管用，以及为什么真正的心理学不一定关乎精神病态者，而是关乎他们产生的影响。对我们其余人的影响。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，这里是“真实的心理学”。嗨，欢迎
along to Psychology Actually. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent, a qualified clinical psychologist and I have another doctor with me today. I'm joined by Dr. Emma Kavana. Hi Emma. Hi, thank you so much for inviting me. Thank you so much for your PR team pitching me the episode, which is all about psychopathy, which is linked to your new book, The Psychopath Effect, the mind-altering power of the psychopaths among us. So, Emma, I thought it might be a little bit of fun to start with a bit of a myth-busting, quick-fire round about psychopathy. So are you ready? I am ready, let's go. Most psychopaths are violent. Myth. Most psychopaths end up in prison. Myth. Psychopaths can be changed. Charming.
收听“真实的心理学”。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，一名合格的临床心理学家，今天和我一起的还有另一位博士。和我在一起的是艾玛·卡纳瓦尔博士。嗨，艾玛。嗨，非常感谢你邀请我。非常感谢你们的公关团队向我推荐这个节目，该节目全部关于精神病态，这与你的新书《精神病态效应：我们身边的精神病态者改变思维的力量》有关。所以，艾玛，我想以一个关于精神病态的“破除谣言”快问快答环节开始可能会有点意思。你准备好了吗？我准备好了，我们开始吧。大多数精神病态者都是暴力的。迷思。大多数精神病态者最终会进监狱。迷思。精神病态是可以改变的。迷人。
A fact. You can spot a psychopath straight away. Fact. If you know what you're looking for. If there are a lot of qualifiers that show, my brain is like, ugh. Psychopaths always know when they're manipulating people. I'm going to say. Trauma bonding is just falling in love.
事实。你能一眼认出一个精神病态者。事实。如果你知道你在寻找什么。如果有大量限定词表明，我的大脑就会觉得，呃。精神病态者总是在他们操纵别人时自知。我要说。创伤联结只是坠入爱河。
A myth. Psychopaths can never change. Oh, that's a good one. I'm going to say myth, but don't try and change them. They have to qualify that one. Therapy is pointless for psychopathy. Is it pointless? Going to say myth, but I feel like that one should be heavily qualified. Thank you. That was the end of our myth versus fact round. So, tell us about what the psychopath effect is. So we talk a lot about psychopathy. It's one of those issues within psychology that everybody has an opinion on and everybody feels like they understand it. But it's like so many other things in science and in psychology specifically that we all understand it, but often we're wrong. So psychopathy as a psychological function. Rather than thinking of it as a disorder, psychologists now classify it as a collection of behaviours.
迷思。精神病态者永远不会改变。哦，这个不错。我要说是迷思，但别试图去改变他们。他们得为那个加上限定条件。心理治疗对精神病态毫无用处。它真的毫无用处吗？我要说是迷思，但我觉得这个应该加上沉重的限定。谢谢。那是我们迷思与事实对决环节的结束。那么，给我们讲讲什么是精神病态效应吧。所以我们经常讨论精神病态。它是心理学中每个人都有看法并且每个人都觉得自己理解的问题之一。但它就像科学特别是心理学中的许多其他事情一样，我们都理解它，但通常我们都错了。所以精神病态作为一种心理功能。心理学家现在不把它看作一种障碍，而是将其归类为一系列行为的集合。
So we have meanness, boldness and disinhibition. So meanness is your archetypal psychopathy. That's the thing you think of when you think of psychopathy. So it's that antagonism, that low empathy, resource hoarding, tending to be cruel. boldness on the other hand is something that we tend to like so it's the tendency to be low fear low stress we tend people tend to be confident they tend to be charming these are the kind of people who tend to function very well in society and then disinhibition are the kind of people who tend to struggle more in society they have trouble controlling their impulses
所以我们有卑劣感、大胆感和去抑制。所以卑劣感是你的典型精神病态。那是当你想到精神病态时你想到的东西。所以它是那种对抗性、低同理心、资源囤积、倾向于残酷。另一方面，大胆感是我们倾向于喜欢的东西，所以它是低恐惧、低压力的倾向，人们往往很自信，往往很有魅力，这类人在社会中往往能运作得很好；然后去抑制是那些在社会中更苦苦挣扎的人，他们难以控制自己的冲动，
they're more likely to have a criminal background relationship issues just because they don't have that inhibitory capacity that hopefully the rest of us do. We talk a lot about what the psychopath is, but what fascinated me more than that was what effect do they have on the rest of us? As we go through the book, so the book is organized in terms of first, glancing at a psychopath across a crowded room, getting to know them, maybe getting into a friendship with them, becoming colleagues, romantic relationships, if the psychopath is a parent. So it follows our progress through the relationship with the psychopath. And what was so interesting to me is that in each of those stages, they have different effects.
他们更有可能有犯罪背景、人际关系问题，只是因为他们没有我们其他人希望拥有的那种抑制能力。我们花了很多时间讨论什么是精神病态者，但比这更让我着迷的是，他们对我们其他人有什么影响？当我们阅读这本书时，这本书的组织结构是这样的：首先，隔着拥挤的房间瞥一眼精神病态者，了解他们，也许与他们建立友谊，成为同事，浪漫关系，如果精神病态者是父母。所以它跟随我们在与精神病态者的关系中的进展。对我来说最有趣的是，在每一个阶段，他们都有不同的影响。
on us. So they have a pronounced capacity to affect our cognitions, our emotions, even our sense of reality, you know, what we understand the world and ourselves to be. So the psychopath effect is about psychopathy, but more than that, it's about us and it's about how we react to psychopathy. Thank you. I really enjoyed the book, and I really liked the way that it was structured with those kind of different relationships. And one of my favourite bits was that you used kind of real-life examples of people who probably would have scored quite highly,
对我们。因此，他们对我们的认知、情绪甚至现实感（你知道我们对世界和我们自身的理解）有着显著的影响。所以精神病态效应是关于精神病态的，但不仅如此，它是关于我们的，是关于我们如何对精神病态做出反应的。谢谢。我真的很喜欢这本书，我非常喜欢它以那种不同的关系来构建的方式。我最喜欢的部分之一是你使用了现实生活中的例子，关于那些可能得分相当高的人，
high-profile people, for example, there was someone that had been a big player in kind of the kind of Nazi movement was in it. And I just found that really helped me to think, right, okay, oh, yeah, I can see how that plays out. But also it was really helpful to think, actually these might be people that we'd meet on our way up in a career or we might be, you know, shoulder to shoulder trying to go for the same jobs and how that's going to impact us.
例如备受瞩目的人物，里面有一个曾是纳粹运动中大角色的人。我发现这真的帮助我去想，对，好吧，哦，是的，我能看到那是如何发挥作用的。而且这也非常有帮助，让我去想，实际上这些人可能是我们在职业生涯上升期会遇到的人，或者我们可能，你知道，并肩作战去争取同样的工作，以及这将如何影响我们。
So I really liked that kind of real world kind of how to spot a psychopath aspect as well. I think that's part of how our understanding of psychopathy has changed because we've traditionally, because psychopathy was treated as a disorder, these weren't the kind of people that we'd were shoulders with. You know, in the book, I talk about the extremes. So like Ted Bundy, you know, the kind of people who you read about in the news. But odds are you're not going to bump into those. You know, statistically, you'd be quite unlucky to meet a Ted Bundy. But as our understanding of psychopathy has evolved, we've realized that the lower levels of psychopathic traits tend to affect all of us, you know, what we can call it a dimensional personality trait. So meanness, boldness,
所以我真的很喜欢那种现实世界中如何识别精神病态者的方面。我认为这部分反映了我们对精神病态理解的变化，因为传统上，由于精神病态被视为一种障碍，这些并不是我们会与之并肩共事的人。你知道，在书中，我谈到了极端情况。比如泰德·邦迪，你知道，那种你在新闻中读到的人。但你很可能不会碰上那样的人。你知道，从统计学上讲，遇到一个泰德·邦迪是相当不幸的。但随着我们对精神病态理解的演变，我们意识到较低水平的精神病态特质往往会影响我们所有人，你知道，我们可以称之为维度的个性特质。所以卑劣感、大胆感，
and disinhibition, we all have those traits. You know, we all have a certain level of meanness within us. We all have a certain level of boldness and of disinhibition. The difference is when we're talking about somebody who would score as a psychopath is that they're looking at higher levels of those behavioural traits. But it is very much a societal issue. You know, and as we're, as you saw in the book, I interviewed people who's, who had real life experiences with people high and psychopathic traits. And there was no shortage. And the fun thing is you say, I'm writing a book about psychopaths and everybody, everybody will say, well, there was this guy. You know, everybody, has a story. It's so interesting what happens when you remove the disorder element. You know,
和去抑制，我们所有人都有这些特质。你知道，我们所有人内心都有一定程度的卑劣感。我们所有人都有一定程度的大胆感和去抑制。不同之处在于，当我们谈论会被评分为精神病态的人时，他们表现出的是更高水平的那些行为特质。但这绝对是一个社会问题。你知道，正如你在书中看到的，我采访了那些对具有高精神病态特质的人有真实生活经历的人。而且这样的人并不短缺。有趣的是，你说，我在写一本关于精神病态者的书，每个人，每个人都会说，哦，有这么个家伙。你知道，每个人都有一个故事。当你移除障碍元素时发生的事情是如此有趣。你知道，
when you start looking at the subclinical, just below that threshold, how much it kind of proliferates out and how pronounced of an issue it becomes. Yeah, I think your book has changed the way I think about people for sure. Is that a good thing? Or have I ruined people for you? Well, a little bit of both. A little bit from column A, little bit from column B. Even the conversations I was having in the hairdressers on Friday, you know, about antagonism. Like, I think the word antagonism is ruined for me now. It's never going to make me not, right, okay, let's have a little look at that. But it's, it's, because I do a lot of work with people who've experienced complex trauma, so we've often met people that are really not good people. It's really helped me think about formulating with them
当你开始审视亚临床、刚好低于那个阈值的东西时，它扩散得有多么严重，以及它变成了一个多么显著的问题。是的，我认为你的书确实改变了我对人的看法。这是件好事吗？还是我把你在人们心中的形象毁了？嗯，两者都有点吧。A面有一点，B面有一点。甚至我周五在美发沙龙进行的谈话，你知道，关于对抗性。就像，我觉得“对抗性”这个词现在对我来说被毁了。它永远不会让我停止，对吧，好吧，让我们稍微看看那个。但是，这是因为我做了很多与经历过复杂创伤的人合作的工作，所以我们经常遇到那些真的不是好人的人。它真的帮助我思考如何与他们制定方案。
in a different way. Like it was never your fault and maybe, you know, there was never and maybe anything you could have done that was any different once you'd kind of been locked in their sights. And I think that that can be very dis-shaming in itself
用一种不同的方式。就像那绝不是你的错，也许，你知道，一旦你被他们锁定，你可能永远不会，也许你做任何不同的事情都不行。我认为这本身就可以极大地消除羞耻感。
and kind of putting that responsibility firmly outside of your control and back into the court of the person with the high psychopathy score. And what's so interesting. So when I started research, in the book. The one thing I knew I wanted to talk about was what happens if you have somebody with high psychopathic traits who is a parent. And my comfort blanket for anything is the research.
并且某种程度上将这种责任牢牢地从你的控制之外转移出去，重新放回到高精神病态得分者的法庭上。最有趣的是。所以当我开始研究这本书时。我唯一知道我想谈的是，如果你有一个具有高精神病态特质且是父母的人，会发生什么。我面对任何事情的舒适毯就是研究。
So when I wanted to understand what that looked like, I went straight into the psychological research. And there was nothing. There were a handful of studies. I spoke to one brilliant researcher Adele Forth, who was in Carlton University in Canada. And she was incredibly helpful and has done the study on parental psychopathy. But it was stunning that it was a case of the study. You know, there was so little research done. And for those people, I started doing a series of interviews because I had to find out myself because there just wasn't anything there. And what was so fascinating with these individuals who had been raised by somebody who they can now identify as having psychopathic traits is they had gone through life, never knowing what was wrong, but always feeling that there was something wrong with them. And what you would see is they had gone to, they would have histories of anxiety, depression, PTSD, chronic ill health.
所以当我想要理解那是什么样子时，我直接深入了心理学研究。结果什么也没有。只有寥寥几项研究。我采访了一位杰出的研究员阿黛尔·福斯（Adele Forth），她在卡尔顿大学工作在加拿大。她极其乐于助人，并且做过关于父母精神病态的研究。但令人震惊的是，这竟然是一个案例研究。你知道，做过的研究太少了。对于那些人，我开始做一系列采访，因为我必须亲自去寻找答案，因为那里真的什么也没有。而这些被抚养长大的人是如此迷人，他们现在可以识别出抚养他们的人具有精神病态特质，他们一生都从未知道出了什么问题，但总是觉得他们自己身上出了什么问题。你会发现他们曾去过，他们有焦虑、抑郁、创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）、慢性健康不佳的历史。
and they would go for psychological support, always saying there's something wrong with me. And what happened when they were unable, when they were able to correctly locate the problem, when they were able to say, actually, perhaps the problem wasn't me. Perhaps the problem was that my parent had psychopathic traits, which massively influenced the way in which they parented me. And what happened then was really quite fascinating. In terms of mental health, they were able to function in a far more healthy way. They were able to, there's something really powerful about that saying it wasn't about me. You know, it was about them. And what the research suggests is that even if they didn't remove themselves from their parent, you know, we're talking about adults. now, but most of them maintain relationships with the psychopathic parent. A lot of them, the majority of them, looked after them in their old age. But even doing that, even still being in that environment, the difference in mental health when you can locate the problem, as opposed to
他们会去寻求心理支持，总是说我身上出了问题。当他们不能时，当他们能够准确找到问题所在时，当他们能够说，实际上，也许问题不在于我。也许问题在于我的父母有精神病态特质，这极大地影响了他们养育我的方式。接下来发生的事情真的相当迷人。在心理健康方面，他们能够以一种更加健康的方式运作。他们能够，有一种非常强大的力量在于说，这与我无关。你知道，这与他们有关。研究表明，即使他们没有把自己从父母身边拉开（我们现在说的是成年人，但他们大多数人与患有精神病态的父母保持着联系。他们中的很多人，大多数人在他们晚年照顾他们。但即使那样做，即使仍然处于那种环境中，当你能找到问题所在时，与
when you think it's you, is staggering. There's something really powerful about being able to say, this didn't start with me. Yeah. And also, almost that you can choose to not be riled or choose not to be affected or choose to mildly dissociate in order to get through to just be able to do the physical care jobs associated with looking after your parents. But know that actually this isn't about me. You know, any other child that had been born or in their power would have likely had the same experience. And it wasn't my fault and I deserve something different. Yeah, absolutely. And, you know, in terms of, it's so difficult. I think for those were that,
当你认为那是你自己的时候，心理健康的差异是惊人的。能够说“这并不是由我开始的”，这具有非常强大的力量。是的。而且，几乎你可以选择不被激怒，选择不受影响，或者选择轻微解离以度过难关，从而能够做与照顾父母相关的体力活。但要知道实际上这与我无关。你知道，任何其他出生在他们权力之下的孩子都可能会有同样的经历。这不是我的错，我值得拥有不同的东西。是的，绝对的。而且，你知道，就……而言，太难了。我认为对那些人来说，
was the group that affected me more than any other because their entire their identity, their worldview, everything had been built by a psychopath. That's a really dangerous place to be. And, you know, we think of psychopaths as being bad guys because that's what society has kind of taught us. But all of these people, all of the psychopathic parents showed evidence of loving behaviours, generosity, kindness. So it wasn't a dichotomy. There was this real contradiction in terms going on. And it was really confusing then for the children going, well, they can't be a psychopath because they gave me, you know, money to, they supported me through university or they gave me money to buy a car. but the problem I think we always have in those situations is that when we find our
那是比任何其他群体都更影响我的群体，因为他们的整个身份、他们的世界观、一切都是由一个精神病态者构建的。那是一个非常危险的境地。而且，你知道，我们认为精神病态者是坏人，因为那是社会教给我们的。但是所有人，所有精神病态的父母都表现出爱意行为、慷慨、善良的证据。所以这不是一个二分法。当时正在发生这种真正的矛盾。然后对孩子们来说这非常令人困惑，他们会想，好吧，他们不可能是精神病态者，因为他们给了我，你知道，钱来，他们资助我上大学或者他们给我钱买车。但我认为我们在这些情况下总是遇到的问题是，当我们发现自己
ourselves presented as an adult with a psychopathic parent we're often not approaching them as an adult we're approaching them as a child again because they bring up every I mean you know and obviously this is your area you know they bring up all of these child like heartbreaks. And so when they trigger us, I love the fact you use the word mild dissociation because I think it very much is that. There is a part of us choosing to go, okay, think about sheep. Or, you know, I'm Welsh, we think about sheep. You know, anything just to kind of to remove yourself from that bombardment of pain, to remove yourself from being a small child again in that environment and unable to escape.
作为成年人面对一个有精神病态父母的人时，我们往往不是以成年人的身份接近他们，我们再次以孩子的身份接近他们，因为他们勾起了所有的——我的意思是你（你知道，显然这是你的领域），他们勾起了所有这些孩子般的心碎。所以当他们触发我们时，我喜欢你用“轻微解离”这个词，因为我认为它确实非常如此。我们的一部分人选择去想，好吧，想想羊。或者，你知道，我是威尔士人，我们想羊。你知道，任何事情只是为了把自己从那种痛苦的轰炸中剥离出来，把自己从那种环境中再次变成一个无法逃脱的小孩子中剥离出来。
You know, there's a lot. It's a very powerful message to be able to say, I'm having a boundary. I'm setting a boundary because it gives you that sense of control that you didn't have as that small child. Yeah, I think speaking as a parent myself, like I would consider my job, you know, well done or done enough if my children ultimately choose to have me in their lives,
你知道，有很多。能够说“我在划定界限，我正在划定界限”是一个非常强大的信息，因为它给了你作为那个小孩子所没有的控制感。是的，我想作为一名父母，就像我会认为我的工作，你知道，做得很好或者做得够好了，如果我的孩子最终选择让我出现在他们的生活中，
they're grown but that they don't need to have me in their lives because they're not dependent and that we're not emmished. You know, I want them to, you know, choose to come out and have coffee or go to the cinema with me or come around for dinner or my youngest always says, don't you worry, I'm going to cook for you. I'm like, lovely, that would be nice. But we need to, in order to have that happen, we have to give our kids permission to individuate from us and to not still be under our constant control. And even, the idea of, you know, once we go into our parental homes, I think sometimes as soon as I put my keys in the dish where we keep our keys, it's that like ching that suddenly gets you back into being
他们已经长大了，但他们不需要让我在他们的生活中，因为他们不依赖，我们也没有纠缠不清。你知道，我希望他们，你知道，选择出来喝杯咖啡，或者和我一起去电影院，或者过来吃晚饭，或者我最小的孩子总是说，别担心，我要为你做饭。我说，太好了，那会很棒。但我们需要，为了让这发生，我们必须允许我们的孩子与我们实现个体化，而不是仍然在我们的不断控制之下。甚至，你知道，一旦我们进入父母的家，我认为有时只要我把钥匙放进我们放钥匙的碟子里，那种“叮”的一声就会突然让你回到过去。
a child. And you need to grow up as a parent in order to let your children develop into young adults and beyond. And you can't still expect to control all of their behaviours. It's like, I can allow you to make an unwise decision that I don't agree with. I can't necessarily allow you to make an unsafe decision as a child. But even those small amounts of autonomy are so important, aren't they? And the thing is, I mean, nothing is more threatening to somebody who is high in psychopathic traits than individuation. Having as having not just a child, you know, a child is kind of the purest example of this. But, you know, for anybody who finds themselves within the orbit of a psychopath. Any sense of individuation, any sense of not entirely agreeing, not entirely buying into
作为一个父母，你需要成长，以便让你的孩子发展成年轻人及以后。你不能仍然期望控制他们所有的行为。就像，我能允许你做出一个我不同意的不明智决定。作为孩子，我不一定能允许你不安全地决定。但即使是那些少量的自主权也非常重要，对吧？问题是，我的意思是没有什么比对具有高精神病态特质的人来说更威胁个体化的了。拥有一个孩子不仅是孩子，你知道，孩子是这方面最纯粹的例子。但是，你知道，对于任何发现自己处于精神病态者轨道内的人来说。任何个体化意识，任何不同意、不完全买账的感觉
their worldview is immensely threatening. And so, you know, you see the wealth of research and psychopathy has been done in organizational psychology. So, you know, within workplace environments. And, you know, you see it there that anybody who finds themselves, with a psychopathic boss. That's a classic example. The level of control exerted will be staggering. I gave an example in the book of staff being unable to decide what color to paint a toilet in case they got into trouble. And it's that level of control. And I think we see that throughout the psychopath's behavioral repertoire. it is very much about I will enter a social situation and I will take charge of it and I will control not just how that social situation goes but how you think about it which is what is
他们的世界观是极具威胁性的。所以，你知道，你可以看到关于精神病态的大量研究都是在组织心理学中进行的。所以，你知道，在工作场所环境中。而且，你知道，你在那里看到它，任何发现自己与一个精神病态老板在一起的人。这是一个典型的例子。施加的控制水平将是惊人的。我在书中举了一个例子，员工甚至无法决定厕所刷什么颜色，以防惹上麻烦。这就是那种控制水平。我认为我们在精神病态者的整个行为库中都看到了这一点。这很大程度上关于我会进入一个社交场合，我会接管它，我不仅会控制社交场合的走向，还会控制你对它的看法，这正是
so damaging to everybody around them. So interesting, so interesting. So you kind of teased us at the beginning that you can tell a psychopath straight away. So I'm going to keep my hands out of the way. when I ask you, when I ask you that question, Emma. Tell us about some of the things that people might be able to look out for. So what's really interesting in terms of psychopathy is you can, evidence suggests, research for shown, that we can detect psychopathy from what's called thin-slice behavioural examples.
对他们周围每个人都极具破坏性的原因。太有趣了，太有趣了。所以你在开始时给我们留下了悬念，说你可以一眼看出一个精神病态者。所以当我问你这个问题时，艾玛，我会把手拿开。跟我们讲讲人们可以注意的一些事情吧。所以真正有趣的是，在精神病态方面，你可以，有证据表明，研究表明，我们可以从所谓的“细片行为样本”中检测出精神病态。
So if you see somebody from across a room, we do have the capacity to pick up psychopathic traits. However, the problem comes when we start to communicate with that person. What we know is that when that thin slice becomes a bit thicker, critically, once they start talking to us, we lose the capacity to assess psychopathy. And I think one of the reasons that that happens is the killer blow of psychopathic charm. Nothing fascinates me quite as much as psychopathic charm. Because in terms of, you know, we talked about their need to control an environment and this is how we do it. Because they are, they have the ability to lock you in, to talk to you in, to talk to you. in a way that you stop questioning. There's some fantastic research in the book. Not my research.
如果你从房间对面看到某人，我们确实有能力捕捉到精神病态特质。然而，问题出现在我们开始与那个人沟通时。我们知道的是，当那个“细片”变得厚一点时，关键是，一旦他们开始和我们说话，我们就失去了评估精神病态的能力。我认为发生这种情况的原因之一是精神病态者魅力的致命一击。没有什么比精神病态者的魅力更让我着迷的了。因为在……方面，你知道，我们谈到了他们控制环境的需求，这就是我们这样做的方式。因为他们是，他们有能力把你锁住，跟你谈话，用一种方式跟你谈话。用一种让你停止质疑的方式。书中有一些极好的研究。不是我的研究。
That's not me blowing my own trumpet. There is just some really interesting research about what happens when we find ourselves face to face with somebody who's very high in charisma. And research has shown that if we are in communication with somebody who is very charismatic, we see a reduced blood flow in the prefrontal cortex. The prefrontal cortex is critical for all our smart stuff, you know, all our logical thinking, rational thinking, our ability to tell if somebody is lying to us. They termed it the guru effect. This is so cool. This is why I love psychology. Because they called it the guru effect. Because when you're are face to face with somebody like a guru who is highly charismatic, you actually become a bit
那不是我在自吹自擂。有一些非常有趣的研究，关于当我们发现自己与一个非常具有个人魅力的人面对面时会发生什么。研究表明，如果我们与一个极具魅力的人进行交流，我们会看到前额叶皮层的血流量减少。前额叶皮层对于我们所有聪明的事情至关重要，你知道，我们所有的逻辑思维、理性思维，我们辨别某人是否在对我们撒谎的能力。他们称之为“古鲁效应”。这太酷了。这就是为什么我热爱心理学。因为他们称之为“古鲁效应”。因为当你与一个像古鲁那样极具魅力的人面对面时，你实际上会变得有点
stupider. And there is an evolutionary logic to it. In evolutionary terms, we read charisma or charm as being a social signal. This tells us somebody knows what they're doing. This person is capable. you know, if this person is capable, high in social status, I don't need to reinvent the wheel. I can just assume they know what they're doing. Ergo, I can stop thinking so hard and let them take control. As a psychopath, you don't want anything more than that. You know, that is a phenomenal tool to have in your arsenal. But the problem comes, of course, when you walk away and you go, wait, what did I just?
愚蠢。这背后有演化逻辑。在演化术语中，我们将魅力解读为一个社交信号。这告诉我们某人知道他在做什么。这个人是有能力的。你知道，如果这个人有能力，社会地位高，我不需要重新发明轮子。我可以直接假设他们知道自己在做什么。因此，我可以停止过度思考，让他们接管控制。作为一个精神病态者，你再也没有什么比这更想要的了。你知道，这是你的武器库中一个非凡的工具。但问题当然在于，当你走开并去想，等等，我刚刚做了什么？
agree to. Yeah, that is so funny. And there's something around the smile and the hand gestures and the fact that if you don't let the psychopath get to you, you can observe their psychopathy in 33 milliseconds, I think. Yeah. Once you get them a chance to start working on you, they get your defences down a little bit. Absolutely. You know, and this is exactly what's happening. So, you know, as humans, part of what we do is read the environment. You know, we, we badmouth hypervigilance, but it's very useful in terms of keeping us alive. And one of the threats in the environment is potentially other people. So psychopathy does come with signals. You know, so one of the classic ones that always gets my spidey senses tingling is somebody who stands that a little bit too close to me.
同意了吗？是的，太搞笑了。还有关于微笑和手势的事情，事实上，如果你不让精神病态者影响你，你可以在33毫秒内观察到他们的精神病态，我想是的。一旦你给他们一个开始对你起作用的机会，他们就会稍微降低你的防线。绝对的。你知道，这正是正在发生的事情。所以，你知道，作为人类，我们所做的一部分就是解读环境。你知道，我们说高警觉性的坏话，但它在让我们保持活力方面非常有用。环境中的威胁之一可能是其他人。所以精神病态确实带有信号。你知道，其中一个经典的总是让我的蜘蛛感应发麻的信号是，有人站得离我太近了。
you know, somebody who doesn't respect interpersonal space. There are standards for interpersonal space, who we will allow into what radius. You know, the closer we are to somebody, the closer we'll allow them to stand. But psychopaths just go, yeah, I'm just going to stand where I want to stand. And that is a really powerful evolutionary signal because that tells us this person isn't playing by our social rules. And what that should do is signal a threat. But of course, once they start talking, the bit of the brain that's like, hi, hi, this isn't okay, tends to clock off. So it becomes a lot harder. So it's all about people say, how do you detect psychopathy? I'm like, it's a really, really intensely difficult thing to pick up. Your ability to see it will depend on who you are. If you are somebody, who is, A, engaged in a conversation with them, but B, somebody who has value to them, your odds of seeing it are very, very low indeed, because you will then become the target.
你知道，一个不尊重人际空间的人。人际空间有标准，我们允许谁进入什么半径。你知道，我们离某人越近，我们允许他们站得越近。但精神病态者只是说，是的，我就要站在我想站的地方。这是一个非常强大的演化信号，因为它告诉我们这个人没有按照我们的社会规则行事。而这应该发出一个威胁信号。但当然，一旦他们开始说话，大脑中那个说“嗨，嗨，这不对劲”的部分往往会下线。所以这变得难得多. 所以这全关于人们说，你如何检测精神病态？我说，这是一个非常、非常极其困难的事情。你看到它的能力将取决于你是谁。如果你是一个人，
One thing we know about psychopathic behaviour, the constant, the myth of psychopathy is that they can't empathise. Well, we know that that's not true, that they can empathise. They can show equal, if not superior, empathic ability to the rest of us. But the difference is it's motivated. So for somebody who has a high value to them, they will seem immensely empathic. They will be very good at looking for what you need. I talk to people who were early in romantic relationships with somebody who then transpired to have psychopathic traits. They would be so interested. They would be so interested in who you were, what you wanted in a relationship, what you needed out of life, which is great. However, there are a couple of different reasons why you do that. One of them is because you're nice. The other one is because you are gaining information that you will then use. And that's what happens. If you are somebody who is high in value to a psychopath, that's what you're up against. I maintain the people who see psychopaths for who they truly are are those who have nothing to offer them whatsoever.
A，与他们进行对话，但B，对他们有价值的人，你看到它的几率确实非常非常低，因为你随后将成为目标。关于精神病态行为，我们知道的一件事是，关于精神病态的误区是他们无法共情。嗯，我们知道那不是真的，他们可以共情。他们可以表现出与我们其他人相同甚至更高的共情能力。但不同之处在于它是受动机驱动的。所以对于一个对他们有高价值的人来说，他们会显得极其有共情力。他们非常擅长寻找你需要的东西。我跟那些与后来被证明具有精神病态特质的人处于浪漫关系早期的人谈过。他们会非常感兴趣。他们会对你是谁、你在关系中想要什么、你对生活的需要是什么表现得非常感兴趣，这很好。然而，你这样做有几个不同的原因。其中之一是因为你是个好人。另一个原因是你在获取信息，然后你会利用这些信息。这就是发生的事情。如果你是一个对精神病态者有高价值的人，这就是你所面临的。我坚持认为，那些真正看清精神病态者真面目的人是那些对他们没有任何价值的人。
In organizational psychology, you will see a pronounced difference between how somebody would describe a person with psychopathic traits, depending on where they sit in the organization. The people below them will call them Satan. They will be like, this is the worst person I've ever met. He is evil. The person above them will say, oh, he's great. He's great. He's so obliging, so interested, you know, always willing to go out of his way. They termed it upward licking, downward kicking. And it's a really good example of what psychopaths do. So for my money, the people who can detect psychopaths, are the people who have nothing whatsoever to offer them. You know, if you want to see who you're with, watch how they treat the waiter. Watch how they treat somebody who's checking them out in Tesco. Somebody who they'll never see again,
在组织心理学中，你会看到一个人如何描述具有精神病态特质的人有显著差异，这取决于他们在组织中的位置。他们下面的人会称他们为撒旦。他们会觉得，这是我见过的最糟糕的人。他是邪恶的。他们上面的人会说，哦，他太棒了。他太棒了。他是如此乐于助人，如此感兴趣，你知道，总是愿意付出额外努力。他们称之为“向上舔，向下踢”。这是一个很好的例子，说明了精神病态者做什么。所以在我看来，能够检测出精神病态者的人，是那些对他们完全没有任何价值的人。你知道，如果你想看看你和谁在一起，观察他们如何对待服务员。观察他们如何对待在乐购（Tesco）结账的人。他们再也见不到的人，
who isn't immediately offering them anything. Because that's where you see the core of a person's personality. So interesting. It's so interesting. And it definitely made me think that when I'm working in the media, they love it when I use my hands. And I don't know, is that because I'm then likely to be, because apparently psychopaths are more likely to speak with their hands,
不立即提供他们任何东西的人。因为那才是你看到一个人核心个性地方。太有趣了。太有趣了。这绝对让我想起，当我在媒体工作时，他们喜欢我用手势。我不知道，那是因我可能更倾向于，因为显然精神病态者更有可能用手说话，
I think I saw in your book. So are we trying to persuade our audience to believe what we're saying more, I'm using my hands as I speak, to kind of get people on board with what we're saying? Is that why the media want me to do that? We don't actually know. So there's a lot of mixed evidence in terms of why we use our hands. So there's a couple of theories. What we do know is that when somebody uses their hands and I could land planes when I talk, you know, I'm very gesture heavy. But I was also a teacher for a very long. I used to teach non-students about psychology. So one of the advantages is. of somebody using their hands is it helps with the flow of information.
我想我在你的书里看到了。所以我们是在试图说服观众相信我们所说的话吗？我说话时在用手势，为了让人们接受我们所说的话？这就是媒体希望我这样做的原因吗？我们其实并不知道。所以关于我们为什么用手势有很多混合的证据。所以有几种理论。我们所知道的是，当某人使用手势时，我可以像降落飞机一样说话（你知道，我手势很多）。但我也是一名非常长时间的老师。我曾经教非学生关于心理学。所以优势之一是。有人使用手势有助于信息的流畅传递。
It helps us process the information they're delivering. We don't really know why. But we do know that when somebody has their hands in use, that it helps the flow of communication. But it also serves a different purpose, and that's acting as a distractor. So if you are a... tempting to distract somebody from the content of your information. Using your hands quite a lot is quite a
它帮助我们处理他们传递的信息。我们真的不知道为什么。但我们确实知道，当某人的手在运动时，它有助于沟通的流畅。但它也有不同的目的，那就是充当干扰物。如果你是一个……试图分散人们对你信息内容的注意力。经常使用手势是一个相当
good way of doing it. Now, I understand that when I said that, it sounded like I'm saying, if somebody gestures a lot, they're lying. That's not what I'm saying at all. But it is one of those things that works towards cognitive load. A lot of gestures can add to the sense of cognitive load. So how hard the brain is having to work to process the information you're giving. And another one of the psychopath's power moves is cognitive load. So what we know in conversational styles is they'll often talk a lot. You know, if you put somebody high in boldness specifically will talk an awful lot. When you're talking a lot, you're generating quite a lot of cognitive load. And that's a lot. And that's the higher the sense of cognitive load we experience, the harder our brain is working. So the more
不错的方法。现在，我明白当我这么说时，听起来像是在说，如果某人大做手势，他们就在撒谎。我根本不是那个意思。但它确实是起作用于认知负荷的事情之一。大量的动作会增加认知负荷感。所以大脑处理你提供的信息必须有多努力。而精神病态者的另一个绝招就是认知负荷。所以我们知道在对话风格中，他们经常说很多话。你知道，如果你让一个特别大胆的人说很多话。当你说话很多时，你正在产生相当多的认知负荷。那是很多。这就是我们经历的认知负荷感越高，我们的大脑工作就越努力。所以越
difficult it becomes to pick out things that are a wrong or B flat lies. So I think the gesture thing is a part of that. It's a part of turbo charge in this conversation. The other thing it does is it signals social status. You know, if you gesture a lot, you're you're signaling that I'm in charge of this conversation. I'm running the room and I'm really hyper aware of my hands as I'm saying this but I'm going to go sit on them now. Yeah it's hard isn't it's hard to not think about these things once you know them and I think I probably use my hands more when I'm podcasting and then the media than I do in day-to-day conversations at the school gates for example and I hope that would mean that I'm less in charge in social situations. I don't think it means your site my friend texted me the other
辨别出A错误或B弥天大谎变得困难。所以我认为手势这件事是其中的一部分。它是为这场对话涡轮增压的一部分。它做的另一件事是它暗示了社会地位。你知道，如果你手势很多，你是在暗示我是这场对话的负责人。我掌控着房间，而且当我这么说时，我极度意识到我的手，但我现在要去坐上去。是的，这很难，对吧？一旦你知道了这些，就很难不去想这些事情。我想我可能在做播客时比在日常生活中（比如学校门口的谈话）更多地使用手势，我希望这意味着我在社交场合中没那么掌控全局。我不认为这意味着你的网站，我朋友给我发短信了
night. She's reading the book and she texts me. She went, I gesture it all the time. Does that make me a psychopath? I'm like, no, I tested you. You're fine. But it is, it is a way of easing the flow of communication. And I think we especially use it when we are in the teacher role, because we are illustrating our words via hand signals. So let's, let's go with that rather than being psychopathic. Thank you. I think what you're saying is like, I'm not, I'm not ringing your psychopath bell, which I hope that's what you're saying. Okay, so are there any non-verbals we should be looking out for? Sure. So what we know is that when we display something called a Duchenne smile, it's the kind of smile that you display when you're nice. That's how we read it. So somebody goes, hi. And it's the kind of smile that triggers the muscles in your eyes. And it is perceived by everyone around us as a very warm welcoming. You know that saying, well, they smile, but they didn't smile with their eyes?
晚上。她在读这本书，她给我发短信。她说，我一直都在做手势。这让我成了精神病态者吗？我说，不，我测试过你了，你没事。但它是，它是促进沟通流畅的一种方式。我想我们特别在我们处于老师角色时使用它，因为我们通过手势来说明我们的词语。所以让我们，让我们顺着这个而不是精神病态来理解。谢谢。我想你所说的是像，我没有，我没有敲响你的精神病态警钟，我希望那是你在说的。好吧，那么有没有什么非语言线索我们应该注意的呢？当然。所以我们知道，当我们展示某种叫做杜琴微笑（Duchenne smile）的东西时，它是你感觉好时展示的那种微笑。这就是我们如何解读它的。所以有人说，嗨。它是那种会触发你眼部肌肉的微笑。并且被我们周围的所有人视为一种非常温暖的欢迎。你知道那句俗话，嗯，他们笑了，但他们没有用眼睛笑？
That is amateur hour. Because the Duchenne smile is what is perceived as more authentic. It's perceived as warmer. And we are more likely to trust somebody who delivers a Duchessne smile. However, what we also know is it's really not difficult to fake a Duchessne smile. Actors have been doing it for years. And psychopaths are very good at delivering what we want to see. They're very good at easing that flow of communication, of warmth, creating that image.
那是业余水平。因为杜琴微笑被认为是更真实的。它被认为是更温暖的。我们更有可能信任一个送出杜琴微笑的人。然而，我们也知道，伪装一个杜琴微笑其实并不难。演员们多年来一直在这样做。而精神病态者非常擅长展现我们想看到的东西。他们非常擅长缓解沟通的流畅度、温暖感，创造那种形象。
You know, remember what we said. When you first meet a psychopath, they will seem like the warmest, kindest, most interested individual. We like people who are interested in us. And the Duchesne smile is a really powerful part of that delivery system. It's a way of signaling to our evolutionary brain. Don't worry about me. I'm fine. Nothing to see here. You know, and what's really interesting is if we were paying attention, the early part of our threat detection system should have been going, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
你知道，还记得我们说过的话吗？当你第一次遇到一个精神病态者时，他们会显得像是最温暖、最善良、最感兴趣的人。我们喜欢对我们感兴趣的人。而杜琴微笑是该传递系统的一个非常强大的部分。它是向我们的演化大脑发信号的一种方式。不用担心我。我很好。这里没什么可看的。你知道，真正有趣的是，如果我们当时在注意，我们的威胁检测系统的早期部分应该在说，哇，哇，哇，哇，
something's going on here. that that early bit that can detect psychopathy from thin-slice behaviour should have been signalling us the Duchampil is a really good way of disarming that follow that up then with psychopathic charm we're defenceless
这里有什么事情正在发生。那个早期能够从细片行为中检测出精神病态的部分本应该向我们发出信号，杜琴微笑是解除这种随之而来的心理学魅力的一个非常好的方法，我们毫无防备。
wow indeed we are it's definitely making me think about when I used to work in forensic units for impatient settings And people with high psychopathy scores were really good at splitting teams and kind of telling people what they wanted to hear on one side, not on another, causing friction, causing chaos. But it also made me think about people I've worked with in kind of adult mental health teams who have borderline personality disorders diagnoses. And that was something you mentioned in your book as being kind of around quite a lot for people with high psychics. psychopathy scores, I also know just how upset so many of my clients with kind of complex trauma and borderline personality would be for other people to be holding them in mind as being
哇，确实如此。这绝对让我在想我过去在法医病房或住院部工作时的情景。那些高精神病态得分的人非常擅长分裂团队，在一边告诉人们他们想听的话，在另一边则不然，制造摩擦，制造混乱。但也让我想起我曾在成人心理健康团队中共事过的人，他们被诊断为边缘型人格障碍。这也是你在书中提到的一种，在那些拥有高度精神病态得分的人身上经常出现的情况。我也知道，我的许多有复杂创伤和边缘型人格障碍的客户，如果其他人把他们视为
potentially psychopaths. But one that you didn't mention in the book was with antisocial personality disorder and people talk a lot about narcissism, don't they, in the public sphere currently. So could you talk to us a little bit around psychopathy and diagnoses? I think we, psychopathy as a diagnosis is a immensely difficult because of its propensity to come along with all of these behavioral, the means of throwing us off. You know, inherent in psychopathy is a powerful tendency to emotionally manipulate. But not only a tendency, a skill, you know, emotional manipulation runs at the heart of psychopathy. You know, we describe antagonism and meanness as the centre pole of psychopathy. And one of the most effective ways of doing that is this emotional manipulation, you know, cutting people down, manipulating them so that they feel lesser.
潜在的精神病态者，会有多么沮丧。但你在书中没有提到的是反社会人格障碍，人们在当前的公共领域经常谈论自恋，对吧。所以你能跟我们谈谈精神病态与诊断吗？我认为我们，精神病态作为一个诊断是非常困难的，因为它具有伴随所有这些行为倾向的倾向，这些倾向会让我们分心。你知道，精神病态的核心是一种强大的情感操纵倾向。不仅是一种倾向，而且是一种技能，你知道，情感操纵是精神病态的核心。你知道，我们将对抗性和卑劣感描述为精神病态的中心支柱。而做到这一点最有效的方法之一就是这种情感操纵，你知道，贬低他人，操纵他们让他们觉得自己低人一等。
Of course, the problem with emotional manipulation is if you can see it coming, it's not as powerful. So for psychopathy to work as a behavioural tendency, it has to operate under the radar. In terms of diagnosis, I'm not a diagnostician. And the DSM has looked to antisocial personality disorder as, would I? say alternative to psychopathy. You can't diagnose psychopathy in the DSM. You can diagnose antisocial personality disorder. Now, antisocial personality disorder has some of the tenets of psychopathy. They're very closely related. But what it does is it relies, it leans far more heavily on the disinhibition side. It's far more representative of those who show criminal
当然，情感操纵的问题在于，如果你能预料到它，它的威力就会大打折扣。因此，为了让精神病态作为一种行为倾向发挥作用，它必须在暗中进行。在诊断方面，我不是诊断专家。精神医学诊断手册（DSM）将反社会人格障碍视为精神病态的替代方案。你无法在DSM中诊断精神病态。你可以诊断反社会人格障碍。现在，反社会人格障碍具备精神病态的一些特征。它们密切相关。但它更多地依赖于去抑制的一面。它更能代表那些表现出犯罪
behavior, who struggle within society. Now, what interests me, you know, we talk about diagnosis and we talk about disorders. Often disorders represent somebody who's struggling, somebody who is struggling, somebody who is struggling to function within our society, within the way that we have deemed our society should work. Yeah, in truth, that's not a psychopath. Psychopaths are often immensely capable. You know, we've looked at the social positioning of psychopathy, especially within organizations. In organizations, psychopaths rise to the top. The people who are struggling within society don't tend to do that. So I have a bit of a problem, almost using the word. diagnosis because it feels like we are medicalizing it in terms of saying this is a problem that needs
行为、在社会中挣扎的人。现在，让我感兴趣的是，你知道，我们谈论诊断，我们谈论障碍。通常，障碍代表着某人在苦苦挣扎，某人在苦苦挣扎，某人在努力适应我们的社会，适应我们认为社会应该运转的方式。是的，说实话，那不是精神病态者。精神病态者通常能力极强。你知道，我们探讨过精神病态的社会定位，尤其是在组织内部。在组织中，精神病态者往往能爬到顶峰。而在社会中苦苦挣扎的人往往做不到这一点。所以我对使用“诊断”这个词有点意见，因为这感觉像是我们在将其医学化，认为这是一个需要
to be fixed. For the psychopath, it's not a problem. For the psychopath, it's a behavioral response often to a tough environment. In the book, I talk about, you know, how one goes on to develop psychopathy, what has to happen for psychopathy to evolve? And in terms of surviving a tough environment, psychopath is a really good way of doing it. It's not great for everybody else, but for you as the psychopath, it's immensely effective. So I, as I said, I'm not a diagnostician, but even the concept of diagnosis when it comes to psychopathy, I struggle with a little bit because I think that it, for me, it is represented far better as a pattern of behaviours that an individual has developed to allow them to survive and to thrive in a harsh environment. Thank you. So that's kind of more in line with the power threat meaning framework and kind of more thinking about formulation rather than diagnosis. That's really helpful.
解决的问题。对于精神病态者来说，这不是问题。对于精神病态者来说，这通常是对艰难环境的一种行为反应。我在书中探讨了，你知道，一个人是如何发展出精神病态的，精神病态的发展必须经历什么？就从艰难环境中生存下来而言，精神病态是一种非常有效的方式。对其他人来说可能不太好，但对你这个精神病态者来说，它是极其有效的。所以，正如我所说，我不是诊断专家，但即使是关于精神病态的诊断概念，我也觉得有点难以接受，因为我认为，对我来说，它最好被表现为个人为了在严酷环境中生存和繁荣而发展出的一种行为模式。谢谢。所以这在某种程度上更符合权力威胁意义框架，更多的是考虑构想（formulation）而不是诊断。这真的很有帮助。
All right. Can we think about the psychopath in love and why love bombing is such a, potentially disarming an important part of what people with high scores might do. Whenever I said, I was writing a book about psychopathy, everybody had a story. Everybody had, there was this guy. And all of those guys, and it wasn't just guys, it was also girls. But all of those stories began with love bombing. So love bombing is an intense bombardment. bombing is such a good word for it because that's what it feels like. It's an intense process by which
好的。我们能谈谈恋爱中的精神病态者吗，以及为什么“爱的轰炸”（love bombing）可能具有如此强的卸防作用，是高分人群可能采取的重要手段之一？每当我提到我正在写一本关于精神病态的书时，每个人都有一个故事。每个人都有这样一个家伙。而所有这些家伙——不仅仅是家伙，也有女孩——但所有这些故事都是从“爱的轰炸”开始的。所以“爱的轰炸”是一种强烈的狂轰滥炸。“轰炸”这个词用得太好了，因为感觉确实如此。这是一个强烈的过程，通过这个过程
the psychopath convinces you, they are everything you have ever wanted in a partner. It is overwhelming, immensely seductive. And I think it really helps if we think, if we hang on to what we said earlier about psychopathic charm. And now we're more. it into a different kind of relationship. So love bombing is psychopathic charm turned up to a thousand. And what's happening here is it's a way of a couple of things happening. It's a way of convincing you that this person is everything you've ever wanted. You know, we talked earlier about how they are very good listeners in the beginning. They are very interested because what they're doing is gathering information. They're finding out what do you need? What do you want? What are you looking for?
精神病态者让你确信，他们就是你一直以来在伴侣身上寻找的所有东西。这是压倒性的、极具诱惑力的。我认为，如果我们记住我们之前关于精神病态式魅力的讨论，这会非常有帮助。现在我们将其转化为一种不同类型的关系。所以，“爱的轰炸”就是被开到一千倍的精神病态魅力。这里发生的事情是，它是一种让人相信几件事的方式。这是一种让你确信这个人就是你一直想要的一切的方式。你知道，我们之前谈到过他们在一开始是多么优秀的倾听者。他们非常感兴趣，因为他们在收集信息。他们在弄清楚你需要什么？你想要什么？你在寻找什么？
And then I'm going to give it to you. It's very fast. One of the best signals of love bombing happening is that the experience of the relationship is disproportionate to the amount of time you've been in it. If they ask you to marry them on day 10, you're being love bombed, which is highly cynical. I'm sure there will be people who will argue with that. However, you know what I'm saying. It is disproportionate to the stage of the relationship. It's also really overwhelming. And that's not an accident. Part of the psychopathic tendency is the creation of cognitive load. Love bombing is a really, really intense way of creating not just cognitive load, but emotional load. You have all of this attention and all of this communication and the gifts and the sense of Prince Charming has finally arrived.
然后我会把它给你。这个过程非常快。发生“爱的轰炸”的最佳信号之一，就是这段关系的体验与你们相处的时间长短不成正比。如果他们在第10天向你求婚，你就是在遭受“爱的轰炸”，这非常冷嘲热讽。我确信会有人对此争论。然而，你知道我在说什么。它与关系的阶段不成正比。而且这非常具有压倒性。这并非偶然。精神病态倾向的一部分就是制造认知负荷。“爱的轰炸”是一种非常非常强烈的方式，不仅制造认知负荷，还制造情感负荷。你得到了所有的关注、所有的沟通、礼物，以及白马王子终于到来的感觉。
But it also serves a different purpose. And we see this in cults. It's an incredibly common process in the early progress of an individual into a cult. You're really busy now because this person or this group of people, have invited you in, and they're now going to fill up all of your time. They're going to fill up all of your time, your attention. They're going to take all of your emotional energy. Because what that means is there's nothing left for anybody else.
但它也服务于另一个不同的目的。我们在邪教中也能看到这一点。在一个人步入邪教的早期阶段，这是一个极其常见的过程。你现在真的很忙，因为这个人或这群人邀请了你进去，他们现在要填满你的所有时间。他们会填满你的所有时间、你的注意力。他们会夺走你所有的情感能量。因为这意味着不给其他人留任何东西。
So your support system, the people you had before, get pushed to one side. Now, what I am going to say is it is normal when a new romantic relationships begins to have a period of intensity. It is also normal that your social circle will change when you enter into a romantic relationship. Because in terms of social function, there's only so much that we can do. Our social brain has a capacity. So it's really normal to see those kind of changes happen. But again, in psychopathy and love bombing, it's that dialed up to a thousand.
所以你的支持系统，你以前拥有的人，会被推到一边。现在，我要说的是，一段新的浪漫关系开始时，有一段 intensa（强烈）的时期是很正常的。当你进入一段浪漫关系时，你的社交圈会发生变化也是正常的。因为就社会功能而言，我们能做的事情是有限的。我们的社交大脑是有容量的。所以看到这种变化发生是非常正常的。但同样，在精神病态和“爱的轰炸”中，那是被放大到一千倍的状态。
And it's a process of isolation. because what will happen is you'll have this period of love bombing, but it cannot last forever. In order to love bomb, the psychopath is having to maintain an intense degree of control over who they are. They're having to control the one thing that defines them, which is their antagonism. That won't last forever. And so once they feel safe, the love bombing, will end and then the real psychopath will come out and that's when you really see who you're dealing with yeah and having having read this book um i wasn't very well over the weekend and i spend a lot of
这是一个孤立的过程。因为接下来会发生的是，你会经历这段“爱的轰炸”期，但这不可能永远持续下去。为了进行“爱的轰炸”，精神病态者必须对他们是谁保持高度的控制。他们必须控制那个定义他们的东西，也就是他们的对抗性。那不会永远持续下去。所以一旦他们感到安全，“爱的轰炸”就会结束，然后真正的精神病态就会显露出来，那时你才会真正看清你在和什么样的人打交道。是的，读了这本书之后，嗯，我周末身体不太舒服，我花了很多
time in front of a fan and uh watching netflix and it was really interesting because i found myself down a bit of a true crime wormhole and there's a Netflix documentary called worst ex-boyfriend ever and then one called maternal instinct and one called worst neighbor ever. And it was so interesting watching that unfold when I sort of had in my mind freshly all of these kind of ways of spotting the psychopath early on. So I think it's changed true crime for me forever. So sorry. Yeah, do you find yourself kind of a plan?
时间对着风扇看Netflix，这真的很有趣，因为我发现自己陷入了某种真实犯罪（true crime）的狂热旋涡中。有一个Netflix纪录片叫《史上最糟前男友》（Worst Ex-Boyfriend Ever），还有一个叫《母性本能》（Maternal Instinct），还有一个叫《史上最糟邻居》（Worst Neighbor Ever）。看这些故事展开真的非常有趣，当时我的脑海里还新鲜地记着所有这些早期识别精神病态的方法。所以我认为这永远改变了我对真实犯罪的看法。非常抱歉。是的，你发现自己会把这套理论
this to people that you meet along the way? I do. I do. And in terms of true crime, you know, we have a, it'll, the documentary will start, because I watch a lot of true crime because I'm mildly obsessed. Not my, I'm fully obsessed with that. And it'll start, my husband will look at me and you'll be like, I'm like, yeah. You know, I think often what we see is these individuals, Because they present so well when you first meet them, it comes across as a real shock when they then display who they truly are.
应用到你一路上遇到的人身上吗？会的。会的。就真实犯罪而言，你知道，我们有一个——纪录片会开始，因为我看很多真实犯罪，因为我有点着迷。不，我不是有点着迷，我完全着迷了。纪录片一开始，我丈夫就会看着我，你会觉得——而我会说，是的。你知道，我常常看到的是，这些人，因为他们在你刚见面时表现得太好了，所以当他们展现出真实自我时，会让人感到真正的震惊。
You know, like when the emotional manipulation comes out, the gaslighting comes out, the cruelty, the antagonism. All of that was there right from the beginning, you know, that you mentioned the documentary maternal instinct. Fascinating, fascinating one. And you could see it coming. You could see the steps, exactly. And not simply with the partner, but with the women that she was interacting with, you could see the love bombing. And it's a really interesting indication of how we end up in these positions.
你知道，就像情感操纵出现时，气油灯效应（gaslighting）出现时，残忍、对抗性出现时。所有这些从一开始就在那里，你知道的，你提到了纪录片《母性本能》。非常迷人、非常吸引人的一部。你能预见到它的发生。你能看到这些步骤，确切地说。不仅是对伴侣，还有对她与之互动的女性，你能看到“爱的轰炸”。这是一个非常有趣的指标，展示了我们是如何陷入这些境地的。
Because the one constant of everybody I've ever spoken to who have been in romantic relationships with somebody with psychopathic traits is how did I not see? how did I let this happen to myself? And the answer is you couldn't see. We can only assess the behavior that is presented to us. And as their target, that would not have been presented to you. You know, I will add a proviso to that. Our capacity to inhibit our worst selves will always fall down when we are sick, when we are stressed,
因为我交谈过的所有与有精神病态特质的人有过浪漫关系的人，他们每个人都有一个共同点，那就是：我怎么没看出来？我怎么让自己落得这般田地？而答案是：你根本看不出来。我们只能评估呈现在我们面前的行为。作为他们的目标，那种行为是不会呈现在你面前的。你知道，我要对此补充一个前提。我们抑制最坏自我的能力总是在我们生病、压力大时失效，
and in a heat wave. So we're all grumpy in a heat wave. Hands up full disclosure. However, when somebody is under an immense amount of pressure, often what you will see behavioral leaks in terms of psychopathy, it's worth paying attention to those. If you find yourself in a position where somebody seems like a very different person in those environments, it's worth noting that, you know,
以及在热浪期间。所以我们在热浪中都很暴躁。坦白说，举手承认。然而，当某人承受巨大压力时，通常你会看到精神病态方面的行为泄露（behavioral leaks），这是值得注意的。如果你发现自己处于这样一种境地：某个在这些环境下看起来像个完全不同的人，那是值得注意的，你知道，
you know, there may be a bit more going on to it. I have to say, I've been foul. We were recording during some of the hottest weather in the UK on record. And I keep having to apologise to my kids. Like, I'm just awful in the heat. And, yeah, like, I'm kind of bored myself of saying, it's so hot. It's so hot.
你知道，背后可能还有更多隐情。我必须说，我变得很糟糕。我们在英国有记录以来最热的天气里进行录音。我不得不一直向我的孩子们道歉。就像，我在炎热天气里简直糟糕透顶。而且，是的，就像我自己也厌倦了说，太热了。太热了。
Like, it's a revelation. It's like, did you not notice? What did you raise? Oh, I have loved chatting with you. There's so much you haven't had a chance to cover. But I thought, can we do a very quick fire round to finish, Emma? Of course. Yes, of course we can. Okay.
就像这是一个新发现。就像，你们没注意到吗？你抚养了什么？哦，我非常喜欢和你的这次聊天。还有很多你没有机会涉及的内容。但我想，艾玛，我们能以一轮非常快速的快问快答来结束吗？当然。是的，当然可以。好的。
What do most people get wrong about psychopathy? The thing most people get wrong is that it is all about cruelty and callousness and low empathy. They forget that there will also be moments of kindness and empathy, and that is what throws everybody off. So interesting. When it comes to dating people or having dated people, the question is, well, why didn't they leave? Why is it not that simple? When you have been in a relationship with somebody high in psychopathic traits, one of the killer moves is destabilizing your sense of self. After the love bombing comes the gaslighting, the pathological lying, and the emotional manipulation. one of its core objectives is making you less than, you know, making you feel less powerful,
大多数人对精神病态有什么误解？大多数人最大的误解是，认为这完全关乎残忍、冷酷和低同理心。他们忘记了其中也会有善良和同理心的时刻，而正是这一点把所有人都搞糊涂了。太有趣了。当谈到与人约会或曾与人约会时，问题是，好吧，他们为什么不离开？为什么事情没那么简单？当你和一个具有高度精神病态特质的人在一起时，致命的招数之一就是瓦解你的自我感。“爱的轰炸”之后是气油灯效应（gaslighting）、病态谎言和情感操纵。其核心目标之一就是让你变得低人一等，你知道，让你觉得自己不那么强大，
less capable, less independent. All of that makes it almost impossible to leave. Thank you. And is it when the trauma bonds are coming in? And it's almost that stunt cost fallacy as well. You know, we've been together this long or we've got these many children or, you know, what will people say? Talk to us briefly about trauma bonding, Emma? trauma bonding is critical when you're looking at psychopathy and long-term relationships, not just romantic, but parental, any long-lasting relationship with a psychopath will have an element of trauma bonding. Remember, this person has told you you're useless. This person has not only told you, they've convinced you that you are incapable, that you are worthless,
不那么有能力，不那么独立。所有这一切使得离开几乎成为不可能。谢谢。那是创伤结合（trauma bonds）介入的时候吗？这几乎也是沉没成本谬误。你知道，我们在一起这么久了，或者我们有这么多孩子，或者，你知道，别人会怎么说？艾玛，跟我们简单谈谈创伤结合吧？当你审视精神病态和长期关系时，创伤结合是至关重要的，不仅是浪漫关系，还有父母关系，与精神病态者的任何长久关系都会包含创伤结合的成分。记住，这个人曾对你进行过贬低，说你一无是处。这个人不仅这么说过，他们还让你坚信自己毫无能力，你一文不值，
that nobody else will want you. And so the logical thing to do is, is to cling on to whoever is willing to have you because you have lost any confidence that you can start again and let alone start again alone. So trauma bond, that creation of a trauma bond, I would say, is almost the end goal. After the love bombing comes the gaslighting, the emotional manipulation, the lies, and that destruction of your sense of self. Once that has happened, you are locked in because you no longer feel capable of escaping. Gosh, if someone is watching or listening to this as a single person,
除了你之外没人会要你。因此，合乎逻辑的做法是，死死抓住任何愿意要你的人不放，因为你已经失去了重新开始的任何信心，更不用说独自重新开始。所以创伤结合，这种创伤结合的创造，我想说，几乎就是最终目标。“爱的轰炸”之后是气油灯效应、情感操纵、谎言，以及对你自我感的摧毁。一旦这些发生，你就被锁死在其中了，因为你不再觉得有能力逃脱。天哪，如果有人作为单身人士正在观看或收听这个节目，
this kind of... They're not all like that. Okay, good to know. If they can be loving at the beginning of a relationship, why can't they sustain that all the time? That's a very good question. So I think what we have to recognize in psychopathy is that just like empathy, lovingness, kindness, generosity are all motivated behaviors.
这种……他们并非都是那样的。好的，很高兴知道这一点。如果他们在恋爱初期可以表现得很深情，为什么他们不能一直维持下去？这是一个很好的问题。所以我想我们必须在精神病态中认识到，就像同理心、充满爱意、善良、慷慨一样，这些都是有动机的行为。
Now, I mean, that's true for all of us. In a heat way, few of us are loving, generous and nice. So we all have that element of motivation when we behave well towards others. However, when we are talking about our closest social service, that for most of us, that tends to be removed. You know, we are, we treat them well because we treat them well, because, you know, there are children. You know, of course we do. For a psychopath, that is different. One of the fascinating things I came across when writing the book is inverted social reward. Most of us get a dopamine rush from interacting well with others, from having a nice
现在，我的意思是，这对我们所有人都是如此。在热浪中，我们中很少有人是充满爱心、慷慨和友善的。所以当我们对他人表现良好时，我们都有那种动机的成分。然而，当我们谈论我们最亲密的社交圈时，对于我们大多数人来说，那种动机往往被移除了。你知道，我们是，我们对他们好，因为我们对他们好，因为，你知道，有孩子们。你知道，我们当然会这样做。对于精神病态者来说，这则不同。我在写书时遇到的最迷人的事情之一是倒置的社会奖励（inverted social reward）。我们大多数人从与他人良好互动、进行一次美好的
conversation, you know, from getting on well and having a good laugh, most of us get a sense of reward from that, a dopamine rush. Psychopaths do not. What has been, what research has shown is that they instead experience an inverted sense of social reward. So they will get their dopamine rush from creating carnage. They will get a sense of reward from causing. trouble, starting arguments, if you ever heard that person's always spoiling for a fight. That's why, because they genuinely will feel a rush of reward from that negative social interaction. The other thing that's related to psychopathy is negative social potency. You know, that having the power to cause trouble in a relationship is really appealing to
对话中获得多巴胺冲击，你知道，从相处融洽和开怀大笑中，我们大多数人从中获得一种奖励感，一种多巴胺冲击。精神病态者则不然。研究表明，他们经历的其实是一种倒置的社会奖励感。因此，他们会从制造混乱中获得多巴胺冲击。他们会从惹事生非、挑起争端中获得奖励感，如果你听过那种人总是“随时准备打架”。这就是为什么，因为他们确实会从那种消极的社交互动中感受到奖励的冲击。与精神病态相关的另一件事是消极社会效能（negative social potency）。你知道，在一段关系中拥有挑起麻烦的力量对
psychopaths. So you will never get them maintaining the niceness because it's just not rewarding. Gosh, wow, that really is food for thought, isn't it? Like, watch out. Okay, final one. Is it possible to read your book, The Psychopath Effect, and not think that either you are psychopathic, the reader, not you, or someone you know or have dated in the past. Is it physically possible? Is it physically possible? I don't know. I get off. ask this a lot, and I have heard a lot of people message me going, just reassure me, I'm not actually psychopathic. What I will say is we all have the traits that are displayed within psychopathy, but what makes you psychopathic is the extent to which you have them. And one
精神病态者来说极具吸引力。所以你永远无法让他们维持友善，因为这根本没有任何奖励。天哪，哇，这真的很让人深思，对吧？就像，小心点。好的，最后一个问题。有没有可能读了你的书《精神病态效应》（The Psychopath Effect），却不认为要么你（读者，不是你本人）具有精神病态，要么你认识或过去约会过的人具有精神病态？这在物理上可能吗？这在物理上可能吗？我不知道。我经常被问到这个问题，我听到很多人发信息给我说：安抚我一下吧，我其实没有精神病态。我要说的是，我们所有人都有精神病态中所表现出来的特质，但让你成为精神病态者的，是这些特质的程度。而且一个人
should not be judged on how one behaves during a heat wave. Absolutely. Absolutely. Could not agree more. Otherwise, you'd be locking me up, I think, because I am foul in a heat wave. Could you tell us a little bit more about you and where our audience can connect with you, Emma? So I am the author of, I think we decided nine, possibly, fiction books. I have written crime for a very long time, psychological crime. I have written The Psychopath Effects and an e-book, How to be Broken, which was about COVID and trauma and, you know, all that kind of stuff. I am available periodically on social media. But generally speaking, I'm writing constantly,
不应该因其在热浪期间的行为而被评判。绝对的。绝对的。不能再同意了。否则你得把我关起来，我想，因为我在热浪中简直糟糕透顶。你能多跟我们聊聊你自己，以及我们的观众在哪里可以联系到你吗，艾玛？我是，我想我们定下来有九本，可能吧，小说作品的作者。我写犯罪小说已经很长时间了，心理犯罪类。我写了《精神病态效应》，还有一本电子书《如何破碎》（How to be Broken），那是关于新冠疫情、创伤，你知道的，诸如此类的事情。我偶尔会在社交媒体上出现。但总的来说，我一直在不停地写作，
so I keep floating across people's awareness. Great. If people wanted to follow you on social media, where would be the best place to do that? I am on multiple social media platforms, so blue sky and threads at MLK. I will be posting updates about books on those platforms. For dog-related content, I'm also on Instagram under Dr. Emma Kavana. Amazing. Thank you so much.
所以我一直在人们的视野中若隐若现。太棒了。如果人们想在社交媒体上关注你，最好的地方是哪里？我在多个社交媒体平台上都有账号，所以在BlueSky和Threads上是@MLK。我会在这些平台上发布有关书籍的更新。关于狗狗相关的内容，我还在Instagram上，账号是Dr. Emma Kavana。太棒了。非常感谢。
And yeah, thank you for writing this book, because like I said, I did really enjoy it, and it's really made me think differently about my clinical work. So thank you. I definitely do recommend it. Thanks for your time, Emma. Thank you so much. What an absolute treat to speak with Dr. Emma. I hope that you've really enjoyed this episode. If you have, I think you'll also really, really love her book.
是的，谢谢你写了这本书，因为就像我说的，我真的很喜欢它，它确实让我对我的临床工作有了不同的思考。所以谢谢你。我绝对强烈推荐它。谢谢你的时间，艾玛。非常感谢。与艾玛博士交谈绝对是一种享受。我希望你真的很喜欢这一期节目。如果你喜欢，我想你也一定会非常非常喜欢她的书。
It's honestly blown my mind. So do check out the reviews or grab your own copy of the Psychopath Effect by clicking the link in the description or in the show notes. And if you're all this talk of psychology and kind of formulation and, you know, making sense of people has wet your appetite because you want to be a qualified psychologist one day. Why not check out the aspiring psychologist membership, which you can join from just £30 a month with no minimum term. And if you'd like to grab your free psychology success guide, you can get that from my website, www.spiring hyphen psychologist.com.uk.
说实话，它彻底震撼了我的心灵。所以一定要去看看书评，或者通过点击描述栏或节目笔记中的链接购买一本属于你自己的《精神病态效应》。如果所有这些关于心理学、构想（formulation）以及理解人类的谈话让你胃口大开，因为你渴望有一天能成为一名合格的心理学家。为什么不看看“有抱负的心理学家会员计划”（aspiring psychologist membership）呢？只需每月30英镑起即可加入，且无最低期限要求。如果你想获取免费的心理学成功指南（psychology success guide），你可以从我的网站获取，网址是www.spiring hyphen psychologist.com.uk。
Scroll right down at the bottom of that page, you can grab your free guide there. enjoy learning a little bit about psychology and real crime and forensic psychology. I think you'll really enjoy the episode I did with the wonderful Dr. Dana Anderson, which is all about the killer psychologist, which is her own experiences of growing up in America, in a complex trauma environment, the sense she made of that and how she ultimately went on to become a forensic psychologist. It was a real treat to speak with her. and her words have really stayed with me. So if you haven't yet watched that one, check that out.
一直向下滚动到该页面的底部，你就可以在那里获取你的免费指南。喜欢了解一点心理学、真实犯罪和法医心理学。我想你会非常喜欢我和出色的达娜·安德森（Dana Anderson）博士一起录制的这一期节目，内容完全是关于杀手心理学家的，这是她自己在美国复杂的创伤环境中长大的亲身经历，她是如何理解这一切的，以及她最终是如何成为一名法医心理学家的。与她交谈真是一大享受。而且她的话深深地留在了我的记忆中。所以如果你还没看过那一期，去看看吧。
And I'd love to know what you think to this episode and that one by dropping me a comment which you can do on Spotify, which is episode specific now, or always you can drop me comments on YouTube, which I always respond to. You'll actually get responses from me. So what's not to like? And yesterday I learned that 91% of you regularly
我很想知道你对这一期和那一期节目的看法，欢迎给我留言。你可以在Spotify上留言，现在Spotify支持针对单集留言了，或者你随时可以在YouTube上给我留言，我都会回复。你实际上会得到我的回复。所以有什么理由不呢？昨天我得知，91%的人经常
watching content on YouTube, don't currently subscribe. Let's click the subscribe button, maybe even consider clicking the alarm button so that you get alerted when I drop new content. Hello, my name is Veronica Kassova. I live in Edinburgh and I just graduated with a master's in psychology of mental health. Marion recommended me the clinical psychologist collective when I was networking on LinkedIn and I must say I love it. It is one of a kind. It's like a window into the lives of people on the path of becoming a psychologist. The stories are unique, honest and filled with a kind of intangible wisdom only personal storytelling can uncover. A common thread in the stories I valued most was to be compassionate not only with others but with myself too.
在YouTube上观看内容，但目前还没有订阅。让我们点击订阅按钮，甚至可以考虑点击小铃铛按钮，以便在我发布新内容时收到提醒。你好，我叫维罗尼卡·卡索娃（Veronica Kassova）。我住在爱丁堡，刚刚获得了心理健康心理学硕士学位。当我在领英（LinkedIn）上建立人脉时，玛丽安（Marian）向我推荐了临床心理学家集体（the clinical psychologist collective），我必须说我太喜欢它了。它是独一无二的。它就像一扇窗户，让我们得以一窥那些走在成为心理学家道路上的人的生活。这些故事独特、诚实，并充满了只有个人故事讲述才能揭示的无形智慧。在我最珍视的故事中，一个共同的主题是不仅要对他人富有同情心，也要对自己富有同情心。
Also not fixating on becoming a psychic. but enjoying life, grow, and the final results will come as a buy-products. Marianne, thank you for taking the time to collate all the stories. The book is a true gem, and I think every aspiring psychologist should have a copy on their shelf. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
同时不要执着于成为一个心理学家，而是要享受生活、成长，最终的成果会作为副产品自然而然地到来。玛丽安，谢谢你花时间整理所有的故事。这本书真的是一颗真正的瑰宝，我认为每一位有抱负的心理学家的书架上都应该有一本。谢谢。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。